[Music]
play your back over ADT that's great you
[ __ ] s oh that's a weird way to thank
me for saving your life buddy but you're
welcome
shooting me was an act of kindness you
see nobody shoots Oh
taco what's wrong with you you gotta
stop shooting Alan that was my bad
California Highway Patrol that's right
open that armored car job I think some
of their own were involved I want you to
go on the inside going to cover within
the department that's awesome you're
gonna be with a rookie named John Baker
you're gonna be rare in Sicily well in
poncherello
it's a [ __ ] up name are the first two
female names John none of these scores
meet even the lowest standards you've
had 23 surgeries I feel pretty darn good
I'm on a pharmaceutical regimen that
helps a lot really high that you can
ride a motorcycle Oh give me that yes
ma'am like a [ __ ] I like you
thank you
you have nice eyes thank you
what's up I'm John poncherello awesome
man we're partners pretty badass
you suited up for battle looking like
UPS drivers yeah that's super cool this
job is crucial to saving my marriage
what are you wearing my uniform I
thought you'd probably want to see what
I look like in all brown it's great John
it's like you're three beers too
intimate almost of motorcycle cop I got
no emotion this your job fine too 5:30
cops
these bikes they'll never catch those
great job recompense on navona bear
gotcha are you guys talking [ __ ] I mean
they just said they like the bikes II
was pointing at my dick I feel like it I
heard Peppino I think it's small I said
look so buff that you make the a bike so
tiny oh I have to take off I hope that
you're not preying on girls with low
self-esteem
how are you judging them like by by
their hair like how straight their teeth
are yeah that's really shallow real talk
she ate my lunch she ate your ass
everyone's eating everyone's ass now
what about hygiene if you go to the
bathroom and you see some baby wipes
green lights
you look 24 hours solve this case for
your fight there's no way to track this
guy
why don't you scan his face we don't
have a [ __ ] bat computer right Google
you carry me over there Bev I'll drag
you there but I'm not gonna create what
you like and you why I saved your life I
knew you were gonna bring that up just
get it over with
did you faceplant into my pubic Mound no
no that could have swore I felt either
your nose or your lips it might be like
a little look a little bit of contact
when you get intimate with these gals is
oral expected like I ain't as with the
butt oh yeah that's standard boss
yeah that's standard Wow things have
changed I'm gonna get hard California
Highway Patrol think they have some
crooked cops you want you to go on the
inside go on the cover within the
department that's awesome we let you